Right, so here is example number one. As you can see, the Asian session starts here and it ends here. So you mark out POIs. So I do not see any POI here. You don't want to go way far back and then look for POI. Just look for POIs near this price action. So right here, what I can see,
is this autoblock. This candle, okay, you can see it's a clear autoblock with three
value gap. Okay, I could use this as well. This candle here. So let's use that and consider this
week as well. So now what we're gonna do is we're gonna wait for price to tap into our autoblock
which happens right here. Okay, let's go to the one minute time frame again and let's look for
market structure shift, it happens right here. So now the fair quality gap is way way too big.
So in this scenario, I would have used a breaker block, which is right here. Lurlo, Lurlo,
Lurlo, this is the last bullish candle before the multi-d downside. Remember, so I would take my entry
from here, put my stop right below somewhere around here to cover the fair quality gap, BPR and the
the body of the auto block here. 6.7 stop loss and we target something like like
this very well you gap right here. So you're going to see price taps into our
breaker block and we have a push to the upside. So yeah that was a clean 3R or
2R we targeted this very well you gap right here and yeah it worked out perfectly.
So let me give you guys another example.